neuf mois à l'assemblée nationale et les
réformes s'enchaînent pour les députés
yvelinois de la république en marche
c'est le cas de la police de sécurité du
quotidien avec trappe reconnus comme
territoires de reconquête républicaine
par le ministre de l'intérieur
le commissariat de la ville va
accueillir entre 15 et 30 policiers
supplémentaires pour le moment
effectivement nous réfléchissons encore
sur la façon dont ils vont intervenir
mais l'idée vraiment première de la
deûle du déploiement de ces forces là
c'est de rétablir un lien entre la
police la police et la population dans
les yvelines concrètement notamment dans
les territoires ruraux
on va voir ce qu'on appelle un groupe de
contact de la gendarmerie à montfort
l'amaury donc au coeur du sud des
yvelines de manière à renforcer le lien
de proximité qui existe entre nos
gendarmes et la population via des
moyens supplémentaires
autre point abordé les emplois francs
objectif favoriser l'embauché de
personnes issues de quartiers populaires
et lutter contre la discrimination à
l'embauché
un dispositif expérimenté dans le val
d'oise notamment et qui pourrait être
étendue jusqu'à saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes en train de travailler que
le préfet d'île de france le préfet des
yvelines est d'ailleurs au courant de
cette expérimentation pour voir comment
des associations par exemple comme face
78 qui déjà font un travail extrêmement
important de mise en relation entre les
entreprises et les jeunes issus des
quartiers ou qui n'ont pas de réseau
tout simplement un conte par un réseau
professionnel étendu pour industrialiser
ce dispositif couvrir beaucoup plus de
jeunes à l'échelle de l'ensemble de
saint quentin en yvelines
donc on y verra clair d'ici quelques
semaines sur le dispositif précis les
députés la république en marge des
yvelines seront aussi engagés sur
d'autres dossiers la loi asile
immigration ou encore la réforme
constitutionnelle